we've looked at different shading some
of the powers right okay we just showed
that it was equal to 2x okay but what
happens when you start across the
coefficient out the front okay for
instance if I was differentiating the 5x
squared okay now for some of you might
think well it's very obvious isn't it
I've got one of them here I got five
here so I'll take this and I'll just say
well five of them okay and this turns
out to be true however this multiplier
business doesn't always just lead to
we'll just put a five in front okay I'll
show you why later on we have to learn
this thing called the product rule
because when you multiply things
together if one of them is in a concept
things go really really different okay
so that's what I'm going to show you why
when it is constant why does it work why
can I just slap a 5 on the front of both
sides of the equation okay so let's go
back to first principles so if I take
any function and slap a constant at the
front so if I say let C be some real no
one hey you gonna be like okay if I take
a new function and let it be the old
function times a constant okay
what's gonna happen is I work out its do
you mean well it's goodnight to first
principles okay it's going to be the
limit as H approaches zero of okay now
instead all my f of X plus h right I've
got a whole new function here okay so
it's a bit different so I've got C times
this part and see
times that pot is that okay I think you
dramatic so far all over H which is the
fun okay no what can I do with this seed
I can take it out I can factorize it out
but the question is why why can I just
say this say at the front and then I've
got the rest of the women over here why
can I take it out because if it was an X
there was an X here right I couldn't
just simply take the X out or if there
was an H I could simply take the H out
why not
okay well let's think that it's let's
think of some examples now examples are
not a good way to prove things but they
are a good way to see how things work
okay so for instance let's take this
start there so simple I've got a
function X okay what's the limit of that
function as X approaches 2 it's not
meant to be a tough question
so it's 2 right now what happens when I
take 2 X right this is just straight
line right if I take the same limit on a
steeper line okay it's going to get
higher right it's gonna be 4 because you
just think about what this line is doing
you know this line sorry versus this
line okay it's just getting to a larger
number so I can keep on going you know
as I take out these constant
coefficients really what I can do is I
can put this number at the front it's 3
times the limit I started with it can
you see why if it was saying X right I
took the limit as X approaches 2 or say
X
okay I can't just put this is not equal
to x squared as X approaches two quite
different
okay because this would be equal to 2
makes win but actually it should be 8
right so what's going on the reason why
I can take out we can overcome the
reason why I can take out this nighlok
at the front right and I can take out
this number at the front is because C is
independent of what my limit is okay 3
is independent of what my limit is but
here X is not okay so therefore this
part here is just this first so it's C
times okay so if I differentiate
something with a cluster at the front
you can actually ignore the constant and
drag it out there and then deal with it
later after you've actually
differentiate okay so therefore how can
we use this
that's the good of my application um
let's take exquisite okay Lord it's not
the coefficient under okay if I wanted
to find say the equation of a tangent
what's a tangent don't you define a -
I'll give you a clue starts a straight
line that a straight line that what a
straight line that touches the curve
what one point okay so be careful right
a straight line that touches this curve
at say one point well I could draw a
straight line like this and it hits at
one point right so we need to be a
little more specific
yeah we want to say that at the point
that passes through right it's not just
doing whatever it was it has to have in
the same rate here okay like that so we
call it a tangent because it comes from
the Latin word for touch which is ten
which by the way we get another English
tangible thank you so things that you
can hold with your hand these that you
can touch
anyway that's right they discovered
honest it's like well and then they
discovered the origin they're like oh
okay so I want to find the tangent it's
a it's gonna be a straight line okay it
passes through a particular point and it
has the same gradient as that point okay
so this is y equals five x squared
okay let's pick a point like say 1 comma
wool when x equals 1
fine right one five okay
hey I've talked about this before that
X&Y can include all the different scales
okay let's keep going to work out what
the equation of this line is right you
need two things number one you need the
point that it passes through so that's
fine but then you also need its gradient
which is why we differentiate okay sorry
what's the derivative it's just five
times - where's this bring that in to
make obvious that I'm differentiating
disappoints - okay so there's my 10x so
the actual value of x that I have is x
equals one right so I'd say here's my
grade does that make sense by the way is
that a sensible result yes why why is
this I grade be sensible how do you know
what grounds engine apart from the puck
never goes head it's ridiculous
I think it is sensible admittedly my
graph doesn't show it off well cuz my my
scale is not very good but five x
squared it's a parabola and the five
makes it a super narrow super steep
water right and tens of steep gradient
so I actually think it's consistent okay
so therefore if I want to find out the
equation of a tangent at that point okay
what kind of phone of the stream
about its point and I've gone it's great
so just play gradient which looks like
this okay all right so y minus 5 equals
10 X minus 1 and what ball shop where do
I have an osprey form so probably
general right so I'll take that 10 X
minus ten 10 X minus y ok so not so hard
and can you believe that for hundreds of
years no one could work this out and you
guys like oh this is really basic your
little mess